foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar NextGen
lab informatics part 1 transforming
research with new eln technologies
I'm antonina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's webinar is presented by labroots
and brought to you by biobia to learn
more please visit 3ds.com forward slash
biovia
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Stephen Hayward Steven has a PHD in
chemical engineering with the background
in laboratory informatics chemical
modeling and environmental analysis
for a complete biography of today's
speaker click their name in the
presenters window at the top right of
your screen
Stephen welcome you may now begin your
presentation
great thank you so much thank you for
the introduction uh it's a pleasure to
be speaking with you here today
as you you may be aware this is the
first in a three-part series that's
discussing the next generation of lab
informatics Technologies and solutions
So today we're going to focus on early
stage pre-clinical research and the most
common informatics solutions that are
used there and then through the rest of
this year with lab Roots we'll be
hosting sessions focusing on areas such
as process development and quality
control so keep an eye out as those
sessions are announced
so as I start my presentation here I'm
going to move on to the slides and I'm
also going to turn my camera off just to
make sure that we don't run and do any
bandwidth issues while I'm presenting
so let's dive into our subject
we all know that labs are under you know
constant pressure to deliver products
and Analysis and results of high
performance and quality as quickly and
cost efficiently as possible
but you know too often the lab becomes a
bottleneck for projects they get
hindered by inefficiency and and there's
lots of pressure put on the scientists
as well and why is that well in Broad
Strokes it's it's commonly because of a
lack of available resources whether
that's because of budgets a lack of
available Personnel lack of resources or
even just due to issues with technology
in the lab
there's still too many non-value-added
tasks that are taking up scientists time
each day as they search for previous
work they try to collaborate with
colleagues in different locations and
deal with project backlogs
and so if they can't find the relevant
information that they need or worse if
they don't trust the data then they have
to spend time reproducing the work as
well
so not only does that waste time but it
wastes resources and increased costs
we've seen that up to 45 percent of r d
materials are actually ultimately wasted
in in these uh you know extra tasks that
need to be done so anything that we can
do to reduce this helps increase your
lab sustainability as well
But ultimately increasing lab efficiency
it helps ease the pressure points in
getting new Therapeutics to Market
faster
I want to focus on lab scientists for a
moment because too often we talk about
lab informatics in terms of workflows
and efficiencies and that leads us to
kind of forget the human factor as well
a scientist that's working in the lab
they have to move between many different
systems to complete their routine work
our lab systems have to serve different
roles and personas across the
organization
but we also have to consider that
scientists perform many different roles
in their daily lives
it's smaller organizations one person in
a lab could be responsible for all
aspects of Designing a project and
Performing all the necessary
experimental work and data analysis
at a larger organization the roles
become more specialized but scientists
are still then collaborating with each
other in different locations to drive
these projects forward
and that takes interacting with many
different software applications not just
for the lab work but for the
collaboration as well
each day scientists are moving between
in-person work and virtual and hybrid
workspaces something that's just been
accelerated during the the pandemic of
the past few years
so scientists they move between these
different dimensions throughout their
daily lives and that can be exhausting
to them and having to move between
different types of uh pieces of software
as well each time
so we've talked about the scientists now
let's talk about what's going on across
the organization in these different
spaces
so if we look at the therapeutic
development Spectrum we could see the
different types of activities that occur
in each product stream as a new therapy
moves to Market
so on this slide if we look at the
bottom the horizontal x-axis we're
looking at the product development life
cycle as something moves from early
stage research and Discovery into
pre-clinical development and then
through clinical testing and
Manufacturing phases towards being
commercialized
and then we have these different product
streams that you know depending on what
type of company you're dealing with or
if it's a large company it may have all
three of them
um and and even more in some cases so
you have small molecule development and
so in early stage resistance Discovery
you're dealing with chemical synthesis
and screening and then that moves into
chemical Manufacturing
if you're looking at a biologics process
stream you may have you know yeast or
mammalian cell Drive processes or ones
that are more individualized patient
provided ingredients as you move to uh
you know smaller patient populations
um as you move up this vertical y-axis
and then for biologics you're moving
into a biologic process development and
clinical testing or other biologics
process
and so all of those first three ones are
delivery to Patient populations
but up at the top now we're moving into
very narrow streams where we're talking
about cell and Gene therapies that are
reliant on ingredients from an
individual patient and then you deal
with biological processes to to produce
therapy for them and deliver it back to
that same individual patient
so you could see these different types
of activities across an organization and
of course that changes too if you have
if you're dealing with medical devices
you have different types of different
domains and organizations in that
company too
but if we think about that
in every section every you know every uh
product stream at every stage at the
development life cycle you have a
different lab associated with it right
as you do the original research of
discoveries you're doing that a first
experimental work to start with when you
do the development and scale up before
you move into clinical testing and
Manufacturing and so there are Labs at
each stage of these processes and so you
know these they may not be homogeneous
either for uh you know each box that we
see here there could be multiple
different types with different focuses
and specializations
and so you know at a large say
multinational Enterprise you could see
how the variety and complexity of these
lab organizations multiplies
and that's you know that's one of many
reasons why we see so many specialized
informatics Point Solutions deployed
across the different domains of a
company
and so if we think to our scientists who
have to navigate these different roles
in their lab we realize how their
digitalized can become quickly complex
and overwhelming because they have to
deal with all these different point
Solutions depending on which area
they're operating in and trying to
possibly
um you know move information from one
system to another or uh pull it from a
different system earlier in the value
stream if they need to reference
something
so here on the you know the bottom
horizontal axis we have the same product
development life cycle going from
research through development qaqc and
Manufacturing and on the on the left on
the the y-axis we sort of talk about the
different areas of responsibility that
these
um Solutions have so you've got your
elns that are really concerned with the
data and execution a little bit of
management oversight there as well we
move into the limbs system laboratory
information management system as you're
moving through process development and
qaqc and then further on towards the
product development life cycle you have
an execution system maybe electronic
batch review and in manufacturing you
have a manufacturing execution system
and that's not even to touch upon you
know the the product lifecycle
management erps other systems that may
be laid on top of this and Loosely
integrated together
um in in certain situations but you
could see how you know it it quickly
multiplies of something that the all the
organization has to deal with and the
scientists do as well
so a scientist you know has to move
between these different systems and
sometimes it takes more time to do their
work on the computer than it does just
to do the work in the lab itself
and then it also makes it difficult to
search and find relevant work if it's in
these different duplicated systems say
you may have different elns spread
across your research organization due to
the different types of labs that are
using specialized elns and so it's very
the only way to find the information is
to email somebody and hope they remember
where it is and then they send you the
file and you have to import it into your
system so it becomes very you know
complex and overwhelming quickly
um and so like I said you know these
Point Solutions have Arisen to address
the specific needs of specific labs
and that gives these artificial barriers
between the systems as well where there
might be overlapping functionality or
maybe unaddressed gaps
and then the systems are integrated
together in an ad hoc manner to try and
simplify the workflows after the fact
but if we really want to simplify
scientists digital lives we need to
eliminate those barriers
and we could focus on developing digital
workflows that match the actual lab work
and build this out from the start rather
than integrating Solutions together that
were never originally designed to be
joined
so in this way then we can streamline
workflows for you know increased
efficiency while standardizing the data
and procedures underneath for better
compliance and overall preserving a
single source of Truth
so I hope that makes it clear why
companies are starting to move away from
siled Solutions towards more integrated
and platform-based approaches
it's not only for the efficiency and
compliance that we discussed
but because when you take a more
holistic view of the information
generated and transferred across an
organization
then you can realize how important it is
to have a consistent data model
underpinning all of it
and so that's the paradigm shift that we
see is that the data that's driving the
Healthcare of Tomorrow is centered
around models where it's possible to
create virtual twins of both the
products and the processes in your
organization
but the way to get there is by
connecting all of the dots across that
organization those individual nodes of
data so that we can more meaningfully
leverage it in new and exciting ways
so many customers and companies are
already using this technology and
probably some of you are customers that
are trying to understand things that are
going on in your process
and so you know the biggest companies
that are in the in the world are already
using technology sets as a Knowledge
Graph
um to better understand their customers
and the decisions their customers are
taking what they're interested in what
would better serve them for a new
product and so Knowledge Graph is
something that's
um a representation of both the
quantitative and qualitative facts
around your customers and products and
it can uncover new relationships in new
ways
and so you see this at Netflix and the
the algorithm that serves you new
information based on what you viewed
Facebook and Twitter are using it so
social networks are are doing this type
of information
um so that they can better serve you
things in in their social algorithms
Amazon obviously uses it to figure out
exactly what you need to see when you
enter into the website
um so there's a lot of applicability
here and we'll talk about how we can
apply that into the scientific realm as
well
but first we should describe a little
bit what a knowledge graph is so we
better understand it and so if you're
not completely familiar with graphical
data models or
um here on the left we have a
representation of a traditional database
which has the data stored in tables in
rows and columns
and generally traditional databases have
a very rigid schema and they can be
difficult to extend so you know if you
want to change something in one place
you might have to redo your whole data
model
and whether on purpose or by accident
the database might be biased by the
individual that comes up with the
original design
on the contrary a knowledge graph is
where the pieces of data are connected
by edges and nodes and they're designed
to be more flexible so they're easy to
extend and you could continually update
them
knowledge graphs are where we we don't
let our prejudices direct where the
results come from
we have the results and we could follow
those nodes and edges and sometimes get
surprising conclusions
and that's the really the advantage of a
Knowledge Graph and and really what we
want to take advantage of in the next
generation of lab informatics Solutions
so for scientific applications how do we
see this knowledge graph technology
helping us to do better science
but one of the features of this is that
you can combine your actual data that
you've run in the lab with data that
you've created for modeling and
simulations
as well as combining that with data that
you can find out on the real world in
the internet to infer deeper
relationships and enable Analytics
for scientists this sort of Technology
could help suggest similar experiments
so you know if I start drafting an
experiment or a plan for an experiment
in my electronic lab notebook
based on the information that you're
entering and comparing mu compare that
to the ontology that's been set up in
the system and it might suggest similar
experiments or maybe even experiments
that have already been done
so that could give you a better starting
point for your experimental work with
analytical methods and we'll we'll talk
about a proof of concept about this in
the analytical space in a little bit
you could easily suggest a starting
method for a new compound or a material
that you needed to develop
and you do the same thing for
formulations and so on and so forth
and for the data scientists in your
organization these knowledge graphs
provide Advanced query abilities so you
could start building those connections
between data points that you may not
have thought of intuitively out of the
box
and you can then combine your
experimental data as I mentioned
previously with data that's available on
the Internet or in simulations and
models
and so all of this is combined to help
address the the fair data schema or
similar that's somewhat of a buzzword in
the industry but it's super important
and I think that's why everyone is
talking about it so much
so let's talk about how it all works
here's here's a little bit of a primer
in terms of how ontology and taxonomy
are related to knowledge graphs
typically we work with about 10 columns
which is a standard classical hierarchy
classification of data
and this is a simple categorization so
there's no cross-domain relationships
and Etc
you could think of classifying chemical
entities and there you might have
organic compounds and inorganic
compounds and underneath organic
compounds you have hydrocarbons which
are then you know divided into different
categories and so on and so forth until
you get down to an actual structure or
entity
and then we get to an ontology where you
could start combining those hierarchical
relationships
well here we're discussing the or
classifying the structures of chemicals
and then over on the right we're talking
about their roles what are they used for
how did they behave Etc
we have biological roles chemical roles
and you can see that you know some of
these are safety classifications as well
some of them are about usage
as the same material been used to
different roles
and you could have many different roles
depending on whether you're talking
about an analytical chemistry lab a
biology lab or standard small molecule
chemistry formulations lab
the same material could be used in
different places and many different ways
and so when we start combining the
taxonomy with the ontology this is where
it gets interesting
this is where the point-to-point
relationship that we have in the
graphical data models become so powerful
and so finally as I said adding the
knowledge graph capacity that's when
we're actually starting to combine the
data with the ontology
so not only do we have the
classifications but we have items that
exist in this classification
these edges that the ontology provides
to our taxonomy allow us to understand
much more about specific subjects
and can continually be expanded as we
update the ontology or data
so that's all well and good but how can
we apply that to lab informatics
Solutions
so if we look at an eln let's think
about what we use it for
we're using it you know as you create
and perform an experiment so you're
you're writing down the um the project
ideas and then the experimental results
there
any of the data that you get out of it
whether it's structured or unstructured
that's getting stored in the eln as well
you need to create the audit trails and
so you're you're creating proof of the
IP there
and you're using it to search and access
other knowledge across the organization
as well
and so some of that's changing too as
vendors expand the capabilities and the
Integrations for the elns and they're
moving towards something that's more of
a central knowledge repository and
management system
but the question is you know can we do
more with the data that's stored in the
eln especially with all of the
unstructured data that's generally just
sort of written down in free text form
and and uh pieces of information that
are copied and pasted over how can we
start to extract some value from that
so if you look at what's actually
contained in experimental write-ups
there's lots of common Concepts and
terms there
and so you know we have the concept of a
study experiment and experiments can be
linked to the material so an experiment
has to use that material of course and
then the experiment could be used to
develop a method or it could leverage a
method that's already in place
the methods are related to equipments
and samples
and the methods also generate results
and so on and so forth and so you could
see that the whole laboratory schema can
be set out in this fashion in a
graphical database that we could take
advantage of
so if you could automatically extract
and parameterize the data as it's
entered into the elm that opens up a
world of possibilities to use the data
in other ways either immediately or as
part of data science initiatives on
larger data sets
so one proof of concept that we
investigated at biovia to sort of prove
that this type of data model can work
the way we wanted it to was around
chiral hplc analytical methods
hplc method development is used in a
variety of Industries for a variety of
purposes
and hplc Method development you know for
many customers and scientists they have
their starting columns and methods
pretty well defined for the material
that they're working with
or for chiral hplc it could be a little
bit more of a Dark Art and so we wanted
to see if we could use data that was
available from you know free source
internet data and predict which
conditions would be the best to separate
separate several chiral compounds
so in order to do this we had an open
source database of compound structures
as well as hplc methods that were used
to separate those structures
we also had an ontological service that
was open source and then we used biovia
pipeline pilot to generate some physical
constants of the materials that we're
investigating to see if there's any
relationships there
and then we took all of that information
and we put it into our experiment data
model which we call spr for studies
process and results
so here's uh just a brief diagram of
sort of How It's all connected
it's up at the top you could see our
chemical classification that we're
looking at earlier as a taxonomy
and then we get down to the actual
structures
here we've generated some physical
constants of their structures using
pipeline pilot
and then we're actually connecting the
information about the physical constants
as well as the structural information
with hplc and Method information like
the stationary phase the mobile phase
and all the conditions that were used to
separate those materials
so if we have this all in place can we
use a Knowledge Graph data model to more
quickly develop methods for novel but
related chiral compounds
so for the actual process what it looks
like the way that it works or you know
that we hope it would work is that when
we identify a new compound of Interest
then we set the ontological annotations
so we're giving it the categorization in
its physical constants
then we would find semantically similar
known analytes so you know other
compounds that play in the same space in
this ontology as the compound that we're
trying to separate
and then we could hopefully identify the
column or columns that will work to
separate out those analytes
so for the proof of concept we wanted to
focus just on selecting the right
columns rather than the whole
development of the method
and then the idea is that once you have
that information and you could prove
that your data model works then you can
add additional information to the column
and then in the future when you have new
compounds you're able to go straight to
the columns and find out which ones
would be able to work to separate out
the compounds of interests
so here you know we want to select the
column find the analytes that are
separated by it retrieve those
attributes of the analytes and see if
there are any commonalities between the
ones that we have already and what we're
trying to separate out then we do the
prediction and then finally add any
extra inferred relationships to the
column to proceed with method
development
thank you
so what were the results of this uh
proof of concept
well we had a database of 23 chiral hplc
columns and 111 analytes and our proof
of concept was able to infer the correct
Relationships by suggesting exactly the
right set of columns 48 of the time
well you might say that's not really
interesting at all it you know I guess
if I were guessing that I might be able
to do better than that but we're not
talking about a binary choose column A
or choose column B what we're talking
about here is actually selecting a set
of five columns where all of the columns
can be used to separate that compound in
question
um at least 80 percent of the time we
were able to select at least one correct
column that could be used to separate
the compound in question so that's
pretty good results
and I think that it's even better when
you we think about the fact that the
individuals who ran this proof of
concept within biovia were not in any
way chemists they are just data
scientists that just had a basic
understanding of how analytical
chemistry and hplc column separations
works
so we're really excited about this I
think it's a a good proof of how
ontology can be used and how powerful
knowledge graphs can be in solving
scientific problems
we all know that going into the lab and
running actual experiments is expensive
in terms of materials scientist time and
in terms of the environment and so
anytime that we can use simulations and
models and graphical databases to come
up with better starting points
and we have to do less experiments to
get um you know our expected and desired
results I think that's a great thing for
everybody that's involved
I know um I talked earlier about elns
being the predominant informatics
solutions that are found in early stage
research
and while that's still true we're
finding more and more that the eln is
becoming a central repository for
knowledge across many different types of
labs regardless of what other
informatics Solutions are in place
so in early stage research you would use
the eln you know to document
experimental results and new ideas
how you're testing out different
synthesis Pathways Etc and and testing
actual product properties among many
other things
As you move into process development
a limbs might be the most commonly
thought of informatics product but an
eon is also useful to document the
progress of projects
and you could document the validation of
synthesis Pathways the outcomes the
different test procedures Etc As you
move to measure the success of your
scale-up efforts
in quality control there are more rigid
testing procedures and batch release
tests that are necessary
and so a lab execution system would
probably be in place
but an eln could be used to help manage
the workflows and the overall project
progress again and it also helps create
the link between commercialization and
the initial product development work
and so you could see how it'd be useful
to break down the barriers and
purpose-built nature of some elns and to
have something that's more flexible and
can be used across the the product
development Spectrum rather than siled
in each area
and that way then you get to preserve
the data in its original format and tie
the whole project together as the
product moves to Market
I want to touch a little bit on
evaluating elns and and moving towards
implementing them and so there's a
number of of steps that you could take
um in in sort of a progressive manner to
make sure that you are choosing the
right eln as you're evaluating it
um and and how to quickly get the value
of it once you start to deploy it
and so once you've sort of launched the
selection process I think the first
thing to to
make sure you do is get the right people
involved early
you need people that are you know
scientists as well as your lab managers
so some of some of your specific lab
users as well as the ones that are
overseeing the labs and understand the
pain points that you're trying to
address as well as people from it
because they're the ones that are
involved with
um the infrastructure and maintenance
and it's at the stage where you want to
Define
um the use cases and workflows that
you're really trying to address
especially which ones you want to start
with as before you expand the project to
a wider deployment
this is also where you'd identify any
barriers to deployment or adoption
um and and start to identify ways to
overcome that and then make sure that
you're communicating early and often to
all of the stakeholders that are
involved
then you need to make sure that you
assess the requirements carefully for
the use cases so really understanding
what your pain points are which systems
you might be augmenting or replacing
because that's that comes into the scope
of it as well and then what your actual
scientists need to succeed so touching
upon the point that I made earlier about
you know it's to understand the
efficiency and to
um to you know increase the productivity
in the lab it really comes down to what
do the scientists need to be supported
and be more efficient in the lab
I think it's also important to establish
a strategic relationship with your
vendor as well so you're looking to find
partners that you can work with to
deploy the Solutions in a collaborative
manner who is responsive to your needs
but can also help guide you based on
their experience and based on best
practices
it's also really important to make the
most of product demonstrations
so
defining the important workflows and
capabilities that you're interested in
getting Clarity on what features are
available out of the box
and What needs configuration or
customization
looking at the ease of use of the
solution and what type of training is
necessary
and then exploring further the
Integrations and configurability of the
solution too
you also have to consider the total cost
of ownership of the solution so are you
going to deploy it on premises or on the
cloud and obviously lots of people are
moving towards Cloud first because you
can offload a lot of the infrastructure
responsibility onto your solution
provider
so you can you can examine that and also
look at what type of validation efforts
are necessary if that's depending on the
space that you're working in
I think it's also a great idea if you
can get value from reference accounts
if you could talk to previous customers
from the vendor and delve into their
specific experiences
identify if there are any common pain
points and and the outcomes from
addressing those
you should also ask about ongoing
customer support and success and maybe
if they do anything differently as well
and then I think it's also a great idea
to try and pilot the system
um if you can do that in a small focused
lab in an actual production environment
that's a great idea as well because then
you actually have the ability to to see
what it how it works in the real world
environment and make sure that your key
personnel are involved in testing that
system
um be prepared for feedback
and to identify key metrics where
possible to help measure the value a
success
and so if we go back to the the
sort of informatics landscape slide that
I talked about earlier
um this is where you know I want to
start to introduce you a little bit to
biovia one lab which is our solution for
removing those barriers across these
different parts of the organization
um and bringing key capabilities
together being able to
um you know manage both the
documentation and the knowledge that's
being generated across the different
labs
to put task planning a procedure
execution together along with inventory
management and Equipment integration and
management and have all of those
together in one more integrated solution
where you don't have those artificial
barriers in place
so for us as I said it's called biovia
one lab it's a role-based unified lab
informatics solution that can be
deployed across research development and
quality control to help manage an SQ
execute tasks to manage the associated
resources and methods and processes
to aggregate data and to look at the
analysis and documentation all in a
fully compliant manner
it has the ability to be deployed on the
cloud for greater flexibility and
security while helping to lower your
overall total cost of ownership
and you know by standardizing the data
and procedures across all these
different types of labs
one lab improves lab efficiency and
ensures higher quality
the data is capture consistency you have
full audit trails in place for
Regulatory Compliance
and the information is stored centrally
for a single source of truth that your
scientific colleagues across the world
can easily search and find and refer to
when needed
it makes it easy to collaborate on new
projects not just you know by the
central data storage but by the built-in
collaboration tools as well
um and you know if you're then creating
procedures that are according to
Industry standards as you move into the
batch processes Tech transfer is
simplified as well
now a key component of one lab is our
integrated eln called biovia scientific
notebook
and it's our new Cloud native eln which
is based on a 3D experience platform
it's designed to be really flexible so
that you can use it across these
different areas in the product device
development life cycle as I was talking
about earlier
um it also uh it uses that graphical
database that I was talking about
um to help parameterize the knowledge
that's created in the eln whether it's
from free text or other data sources so
then you could better leverage it
um such as the use case that we were
talking about but you could expand it
into other areas as well
it gives you the ability to consolidate
and index data from other elns as well
so including biovia's other elns and
other third-party ones too so that you
can index the data and view it all in a
single Source in scientific notebook
it has integration with formulation
design which is another area of our
Solution on the on the 3D experience
platform so you could have integrated
workflows across formulation design and
your eln and it has synthetic chemistry
functionality built into it as well
and so with scientific notebook it
really sort of sets you up to have these
complete end-to-end lab workflows all
across your organization depending on
you know irregardless of which
scientific domain you're working in you
could use the same type of eln instead
of having to have different ones that
are focused for the different areas
and it eases access to the data
you know it doesn't matter where you are
you could simply search for it in the
same type of platform and and track
projects as they move across that
product development life cycle
um it gives you scientists you know
better access to all of the data instead
of hunting for it
um and then they still are able to work
in the medium that they prefer
um you know whether it's spreadsheets or
tables or just typing in free text it's
all available there and it's mobile
friendly so you could do so on your
laptop desktop or on a mobile device as
well
um and it's it's has uh support for open
apis as well so that you can integrate
it with other Solutions you can pass
information back and forth as you need
to and integrate it with other you know
process-based models as well
so scientific notebook brings
um a wide variety of quickly achievable
and specific benefits to an organization
that implements it in their r d labs and
processes
you could reduce your costs by between
15 and 25 percent just by eliminating
the repetition of experiments that have
been already performed
um so things that you know another
colleague has done at some point but
maybe you weren't uh wouldn't be able to
otherwise find it easily or if you know
you don't know where the work is stored
or what it's called uh if you can't find
a reference point to it you may not be
able to find it or maybe you're not
aware of it at all I talked to one
customer last year that said the
lifetime of data in their Labs is about
18 months because after that they don't
really trust
um it as you know if you haven't
leveraged it in a project at that point
they don't have great trust for how it
was captured and all of the context
around it and so like having that source
of Truth in one place where you could
easily reference the original experiment
in its you know its native format it
increases the trust the ability to
leverage that experiment down the road
so it takes you know between 40 and 50
percent less time to search for that
experimental data as well so it makes it
much faster to find it and share with
others
um you could also reduce the time spent
creating experiments by you know 25 to
30 percent
um especially those that are uh common
or repeated in a series you could
duplicate the templates and simply
change the the relevant observations in
that section
scientists spend much less time creating
comprehensive reports since the data is
easy to compile and the reports can also
be created with templates
and so overall this easily leads to
improved productivity throughout the
organization's r d labs
one lab has um you know a number of
these different capabilities that could
be leveraged by an organization and it
enables the the key roles in the lab to
transform different parts of the lab
workflows as I talked about you know the
different sort of categories of Limbs
and Les and eln
but the benefit with one lab is that it
could be configured to meet a customer's
unique needs and then can change over
time to address different areas as the
needs arise or as business priorities
change
so smaller companies might only be
interested in adopting an eln or
upgrading the one they have but that
becomes the the entry point for a larger
digital transformation down the road
or if you have a limbs in place and
you're looking to upgrade from an older
Legacy version you could adopt one lab
for information management but then
there's procedure execution capabilities
that go along with that
and you could tie those two areas
together for more integrated workflows
and better data integrity
or maybe you're just managing chemical
inventory in a scratch build application
or in Excel and if you adopt a
cloud-based Inventory management
solution that could be a game changer
too
but the real value multiplier of one lab
is if you deploy it in one area then you
can expand its capabilities over time
so not only does that tailor your
deployment to meet specific needs at one
point but it enables you to leverage
that investment
and further expand the unified ecosystem
excuse me driving your both the
horizontal and vertical integration
throughout your organization for a true
connected digital lab
so that's going to end things for me
that's all the the slides that I have
um and so I'm going to turn things back
over and we'll do a sort of live q a now
great thank you Stephen for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
now let's get started
our first question here is can you track
chemical inventory in the eln
uh sure so we currently have what we
call materials Smart Text so as you're
typing information into the eln you
could it sort of automatically
recognizes things that have been created
before as as material objects and so you
can link those materials to material
tables for experiments and procedures
and for the formulations integration as
well
um within one lab we have materials
inventory tracking as well along with
safety data sheet management and local
compliance regulation tracking and so
we're working to finalize that
integration with scientific notebook as
well this year
thank you
um and then we can't see you
um yeah if you want to jump back on
camera oh yes sure perfect
thank you for that um another question
we have here is where do you see the
patenting process in this framework
um
so that's an interesting question
um I think that it it's really important
um
basically you're leveraging all of the
information that's in the eln right when
you're starting to uh to file a patent
and it really depends on how fast you
can get to a point where you have all
the information ready to to file a
patent
um so I think that that is something
that that comes in that sort of early
stage research as you start to move from
there into process development you've
got everything packaged up and ready to
satisfy what you need for a patent so
it's it's really important to be able to
gather all of that quickly from your
both the eln and any other relevant data
sources
um
and also publish that in this in a
structured way uh and so that's I that's
something that's important to have all
of that information easily accessible
easy to be collated together and
packaged up and written into a pattern
so
um that's that's sort of where I see it
fitting together there
thank you next question here is is your
knowledge graph a proprietary data
standard
um sure so
I mean really the the knowledge Graphics
it's a technology for defining the
relationships between the pieces of
metadata
um so the taxonomies and ontologies that
you apply there are really flexible
um and we normally align those uh with
things like the allotrope data format or
you know whatever ontology our customers
want to utilize so it's it's not a
proprietary data standard it's something
that uses
um sort of different pre-competitive
Alliance defined data standards is very
flexible to exactly what a customer
wants to utilize
for that
um another question here is users are
often resistant to changing systems how
do you address that
right
um so it's it's often it's the devil you
know right it's it's you might have pain
points in your current Solutions but
you're used to it and you understand
which buttons to click you know how to
move through a process as quickly as
possible
um
and so if you're sort of trying to to
work with users to to
um get them to adopt a different
standard because you see the business
benefits to moving to something that's
more integrated or streamlined or or for
whatever your impetus is from for moving
on from the solutions you have in place
I think it's really important to sort of
lay out the plans in a well-defined
manner up front
um and to identify the the use cases and
the pain points that your users have in
their day-to-day lives and how you're
going to address that and so that's
really about getting those right people
involved early in the process and and
picking off
the
um the specific things that that you can
tackle right at the beginning because
sometimes those meetings turn into well
we've got a hundred different pain
points so we can't deal with all of them
so what are the ones we're going to
start with and and show the benefit
there get users used to using the system
and how it it
um makes their lives easier in those
specific ways and then they'll probably
start to realize how they can leverage
it in other ways too and then start to
prioritize the the different use cases
they want to tackle next
thank you and we'll end with this one
here um someone is asking do you have
API for lims integration general or do
you work with shared data views or files
um yeah so I
um
I I know we do have apis in place uh for
the limbs
um in in one lab and so I know that we
can integrate with different systems
that way that's sort of one of the
access points for it
um I
technical implementation of the apis is
not my strong suit but I know that it's
uh something that that we support and
our our Tech sales people are more than
capable of of working with different
Integrations as necessary
great thank you thank you again Stephen
for your time today and your important
research we'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor biovia for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions any
questions we do not have time for or
those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
any one of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
thank you